[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys i'm pretty sure
you can hear me but let me double check
because there's some super chats popping
up still waiting on the rest of lures to
show up man so let me let me double
check that you know everything sounds
fine i sound crisp
things sound good
all right so let's get these super chats
guys
so we have a five dollar superchat from
warlord one
zero one five lots of channels live
streaming this and as always i choose to
be with the realm with the lords
notification game we in here
appreciate the support man appreciate
the support
you gotta [ __ ] up
we gotta find all this superstar from
gerald mack all hell the iop salute
happy 20th anniversary xbox and happy
bourne day to the lord my man cognito in
my cog voice
i might have him re-read that when he
comes back in because the only person
that can truly get that called voice is
cognito himself
got a five dollar superchamp from lucius
butchered your name from moving right
past that had to come in and show love
to iop and the which hodi is lurious
lord himself cognito happy birthday
brother and here's to many more i
appreciate all that man i appreciate all
that so uh let me uh i'm gonna go ahead
and turn the music back up we'll be back
here in a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so what's going on guys what is going on
i'm kind of curious to hear your guys's
expectations when it comes to this
i want to uh hear exactly what you guys
feel is going on what do you feel
microsoft's doing at this event
we got a super chat from uh
man i i i already know i'm about to
butcher the hell out of this man i
apologize in advance man
uh a lad
show maurice shot you know
it is what it is man i i you know i
can't pronounce stuff to save my life
but he said since super chats were
enabled here only recently i'm happy my
first one is in the realm it is bit of
my boss my shinobi himself a happy
boring day i appreciate the uh uh the
super chat man especially being your
first one man there's definitely a very
big thing for us man uh you know we love
the support you guys throw out to us we
got a five dollar super champ from
raiden blade
hi lords happy new birthday to you lord
cog also i'm extra i'm extra happy today
got my series x halo edition that's
what's up man
that is what is up
so i still curious what you guys have to
say man like do you think this is gonna
be a huge
what's what i'm looking for
do you think there's gonna be a lot of
announcements here or do you
or do you think that it's not gonna be a
lot of announcements but maybe one good
announcement i'm kind of curious to you
guys
i want to see the realms expectations
when it comes to this going on right now
what do you guys feel is going to happen
i'mma read the chat man
got to get this this
got to get these uh
well you guys think
all right so let's see
all right so someone says they're going
to do a lot of history montages most
likely
uh one says halo infinite facebook page
brick i don't think that
i already moved up
saying halo infinite multiplayer was out
and sent them to rock band never going
to give up
if in doubt about battlefield then
remember it will come out ea play
fable trilogy remastered new backwards
compatible games and fbs boost
multiplayer out today
hellblade 2 and gameplay i don't believe
oh my god this dude's reaching for the
size
yeah i appreciate it man uh a fable cgi
trailer i don't think we're gonna see
anything like old like new fable maybe
we'll see something old fable i just
don't know about new fable
i'm kind of curious hold up
i gotta fix something i put something in
its place because i don't know if you
guys know this but you get a badge
depending on how long
you've been a member of the realm
now
we originally did them all but two but
one and that was the
the badge for
the two-year mark well i put one in
there so i'm kind of curious
if
let me look through here
i'm kind of curious if
anyone
is can qualify for that member for the
two-year thing because i know there's
some of you that was really close yes
okay so
there are some of you that is extremely
close to having the two-year batch
now uh there will be
the the two-year badge will probably go
live in a month because for the people
that have been around
for
almo for close to two years now there is
a few like
uh you know i'm not gonna put people's
name out there if they don't want to but
you know uh
you're gonna see you're gonna see some
of the badges in here man you're gonna
see some of the badges in here
there is quite a bit there's one
two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven there's
11 of you that's been with us
for almost two years and that's what's
gonna happen is once you hit that two
year mark
you're gonna have
a badge
of this is what i'm gonna just tell you
guys like
your badge when you hit two years being
a member of the uh being a member of the
channel is gonna be that man you're
gonna have that crisp
iop badge besides your name
that's what that's what your uh
that's what your your your thing's gonna
be man it's gonna be a crisp
iop logo
you won't have like a person besides
your name you'll be you have an iop logo
free xbox after two years now
i don't know about that man we uh
we ain't making that much money man we
ain't making that much money
20th anniversary sell everything 80 off
[Laughter]
that's what's up man that's what's up
that's a prediction that would be cool
all right so we got a five dollar super
chat from chaos might
expectations would be more halo news
maybe early access
announcement fps boost from xbox and 360
then maybe hellblade 2 and fable news so
that's a bold prediction man it's a bold
prediction
there is not a three-year badge
now i do have how long you've been a a
member forte are you okay with me just
telling the chat how long you've been a
member
because i do have the the list pulled up
so if you're okay i'll tell i'll tell
them
elder scrolls 6 is an exclusive phil
confirmed it today it'll probably be a
topic for iop i don't know
so forte has been a member for almost
three years uh two years so he will get
the iop logo beside his name now there
are people that is is
is almost there like they'll get it a
couple months
but as far as the people that's going to
get it next month there's only like
eight of you
uh but you know you stick with that man
you get that iop shield besides your
name
we got two dollars super trap from
raiden blade
show
hey uh
i don't know what hellblade too yeah
show how blake two today and all uh and
at the game of the year fable and avowed
you guys are really you want it man
you guys want that man you want it
thanks for bringing a
little oh you guys are you guys are
insane
what is the
anniversary for iop i keep forgetting
let's look here let's look when the
anniversary is for iop
all right let's look here
so what you do is go to videos and you
sort it by the oldest
all right so we have this one here
april the 2nd 2017 is our official
first iop now there are some before then
what's up miles
what are you doing miles i'm sure you
got all kinds of nice little info
you you can share it with the chat if
you want my house
feel free to share it with chat miles
i might have rock with this account come
forward yeah it's it's that account it
is that account
cognito is not currently here yet he
will be here soon and so will cognito i
mean so will king david we're going to
be a full house just about um forte you
want to pop in here man we got an extra
spot you want to pop in here and do the
reaction with us
we have an extra spot
the extra spot is there if you want it
forte you just gotta hit me up and i
will send you the link
i almost put the link in the chat that
would have been horrible
if i put that link in the chat
like i know zoom can have up to like 100
people
but that would be crazy
hustle
could uh have life stuff to do so he
could not make it but
hopefully
most likely everything's gonna be back
uh
tomorrow man we're gonna be
on the attic show with hustle me and
king david's gonna pull him for the
attic show tomorrow and we're gonna one
of the big topics we're gonna talk about
is the nominations for the video game
awards because they will be live by the
time attic show is tomorrow
i don't know if it's a hundred people
but i know there's a lot i know you can
have a lot
might be able to even have more than 100
people
it's a bs award show it is but i enjoy
the conversation i really do i enjoy the
conversations behind game of the year i
think it's a really fun conversation
we got a
member for three months can't use my
super chat in my region so i you instead
use this salute to iop keep up the good
work i appreciate it man i appreciate we
got a two dollars if you have a raid and
play
it's all about viewing levels is game of
the year verizon uh horizon
forza horizon 5 game of the year
add miles if miles wants to jump on man
miles is more than welcome to i can send
him a link but miles gotta want to jump
on man you can't we can't just make what
miles do stuff
who is the next guest on iop
lord cognito
would have my head if i told you who the
next guest is
so i'm a i'm gonna do what i do best
and i'm gonna re i'm a i'm gonna direct
you to cognito's direction
you can ask him i know he ain't gonna
tell you but you can ask him
house
of game of the year is just a basic
uh i don't think ratchet and clank
deserves game of the year i'm going to
be real with you i thought it was a good
game but i didn't think it really did
anything special
we want you on the stream today i don't
know that man
you're fine miles i'm just telling you
what the realm was telling me
they wanted miles so i figured i'd give
the open invitation because the realm
wanted it
phil spencer confirmed no it's not phil
spencer
i will say it's not phil spencer i don't
want people going around saying phyllis
spencer's coming on that it's coming on
the iop that's not what's happening
is it mama cog
uh maybe i don't know
is it mama cog you guys are ridiculous
now ratchet and clank's not boo boo but
it's definitely i don't think it's like
fantastic or anything
is it the rock
i don't know man
get ran on rain don't really like doing
any type of
any form of what's what i'm looking for
like reactions if you guys want ran on
go on twitter
and tag ran in a tweet
and say come on iop and do the reaction
with floor cog needle lord king and lord
king david if you guys want ran in there
man you guys are gonna have to go on
twitter and do your own leg work if he
contacts me i will send him
the link
two dollar shift right from raid and
blade
i'd love to be invited to iop
i laugh a lot i'm next raise and play
when it comes to
is it alex no it's not like i was
interviewing himself but cosplaying big
bird from sesame street i don't know if
i should feel like ashamed of that like
i don't know man
i am not
big bird from sesame street
yeah miles uh rain probably still asleep
so
so
we got a two super chat from michael
mooney tag ran and an xbox buys a
nintendo tweet that'd be the clearly the
best way to get that man in here but you
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go
ahead and uh phase out my voice man i've
been talking for a minute and i'm i'm
gonna let dallas get his bars off
[Music]
do
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind coming ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the snapple and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
i'm better than money because you can
bank on me being accountable i know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on aim
[Music]
i'm very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a
don't stop
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
[Music]
feeling to be a dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we were messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
now we are alive
yeah we live oh
just to clarify
[Music]
[Music]
keepers
what if he had an imaginary friend like
that
no no he can't sound like that
dude there's already enough mental
issues in my life you don't need to give
me more now i'm going to think of people
talking to me
oh my
god the camera on me real quick we got
two minutes so i could do this real good
oh thank y'all for that for the boy
y'all much appreciate it thank you thank
you hey guys don't look address
don't zoom up on address yeah don't be
zooming and taking in my eye just
popping up my mouth don't kill me
i got the beard
[Laughter]
with the liquor
okay what's
[Music]
good afternoon king gollum
this is it
oh yeah i gotta go pick myself at the
ups joint yeah
you're not stealing and robbing me
policy you're not going to leave it and
then run off and talk about you
delivered it no if i'm not present it
goes to this
you already know they already know i run
down on them yeah
oh i know how you do that yeah they were
like nah we can't mess with that dude at
that house over there hey girl we should
get anchorman in here yeah yeah
anchorman you could come in if you want
maybe we'll come here
you better hurry up though because it's
about to stop i was wondering
i was talking about in command today
so elite series 2
halo infinite edition
kai said why would he come on the king
got a box cut in his hand on the camera
[Music]
there you go
look at that you got that oh
[Music]
oh my gosh it's not the stream yo
what up is it broke oh my god bro's
control is crazy
i thought it was broken oh my god yo you
got to feel the nerves
yo the the grips is crazy yeah that's
crazy the whole grip
uh hey king i received my series x halo
edition bro
you got the castle
and then everyone put a put a logo in
that chat man put put put the logo in
the chat and welcome
raw uh rodale five to the round that
probably butchers your name but this is
absolutely get with the program man get
with the program phil's bananas
absolutely beautiful this is my first
elite two before they started they
started
yeah let me go
shout out to forte time for the brand
jump great much love iop bring the
community together love you guys as
always hey king boo boo hey four two
cedric h
xbox thank you brother
the man of the hour too sweet to be sour
yeah
20 200 20 21 yo
addicts i mean anchor says send the link
the whole uh hold up uh my audio isn't
working it's cool
let me know we might get some um what
you call it today
oh inside the box got the oh joey yo
twitch isn't working for some reason my
audio isn't working on twitter oh he's
talking about the audio for the uh
stream yeah it's just not going through
it don't worry i won't blow up anything
that's uh incredible xbox yeah he said
stream drop they said sound you'll find
and played it yeah it's the audio on
youtube
[Music]
it's special to be back here with xbox
fans around we're here to double i mean
just look at this game
how far we've all come since 2000
my name is robbie someone someone steps
out there
[Music]
how
to a way for microsoft to get into the
living room no matter where
these were audacious groundbreaking
ideas at the time oh my god
you said i'm hearing it four times
we assembled our team and got to work
yeah
nice see what it means
no i i didn't know this cartridges okay
a global dedicated online service to let
you play with old and new friends alike
no matter where they are
these were audacious groundbreaking
ideas at the time
but they were all so risky
we faced skeptics
i'll be honest and say inside and
outside of microsoft
we had missteps along the way
there were lots of challenges involved
did i tell you i love you guys out the
door i love you
and i truly appreciate you i just wanted
to let you know that it took to bring
xbox to life
i always remember that success was not
introducing passion for what xbox is
that transformed that vision into
reality
a vision only comes to life when others
share a problem
and for that we are grateful to all of
you
our partners developers around the world
and most of all our fans that's what i'm
trying to find yeah i see the twitch
link when i go to youtube or xbox they
ain't got no dirt
[Music]
hold up i gotta fix stuff because
anchorman messed up the boxes microsoft
is going to make a game console we
weren't sure how we were going to do it
risk was enormous
microsoft was this dominant company of
the era but success or even survival was
anything but pre-ordained are they doing
like the the recap in the back like the
history and at the same time we weren't
doing anything in the console space one
day these guys went to the idea
we just thought of ourselves
combination of craziness in general
looked at the xbox idea and saw insanity
i'm just going to the steep bomber
partner
what's the hard drive going to cost
i'll go to twitch there's no way
everything about making a console is
hard we i can try
because it's sometimes twitch just like
when i try to go to twitch like it
doesn't like the audio doesn't play for
some reason yeah all you got to do is
hit the screen in the bottom left-hand
corner it's all
your auto mute
nah it's still not playing
how is your twitch not playing music i i
don't know like you got to do is do you
have a volume bar at the bottom it's
completely turned up oh never mind i'm
an idiot it's it's beautiful and then
sometimes the surprises that come out
the thing itself was music i know
is a six part documentary series that
release on december 13th across a
variety of video platforms
three years ago with a simple question
is there a compelling story behind the
history of xbox
the answer it turns out was yes
absolutely
so we partnered with an emmy
award-winning documentary film team to
really dig in and help bring the story
to life
at its core it's a story about how xbox
started as a passion project from a
small group of gamers within microsoft
and grew to become a source of joy for
xbox players around the world
whether you've been here for the entire
20 years or you have just joined us
we're excited to have you with us today
and we're going to relive some of our
favorite moments
here's some words of wisdom from our
very own bill spencer and definitely
have a little bit dominance
that's what happens you want to come out
when the big stuff matters
thanks rock and it really is an honor to
have you here
believe it or not
for instance i know
that you're a five-time wwf champion
not to mention one of the top
entertainers in the world somebody
double
billion very fast as well uh for
instance the rock knows you're the
chairman and chief software architect of
the might feel like it's the video a
leading worldwide provider
it's just bill gates
thank you rock i'm i'm
that was the 480i contained operating
systems that featured networking uh
shout out to the center multi processors
[Applause]
for the first time let me now unveil the
hell is wrong
[Music]
[Music]
was
[Laughter]
when we pay money to play emulated games
hi everyone
who's known on xbox as people nominees
i've been playing video games pretty
much my whole life maximum i actually
joined this company as an intern what i
was saying some stills go get that long
time before xbox
one's out
so when i think about 20 years of xbox
and what guys mean to all of us
i always come back to the fact that
around the world gaming is all happening
you start wearing another body everybody
else stuff games are all about real
people coming together to create
experiences
do you guys think they're really going
to do a self-driving player today
such as
i mean strike oh the iron different
genres but the reality is
with the other dudes
let that baby get his attention
it is you've made our passion as popular
and important as it is today
pretty much every day when i'm off work
i'm on xbox i'm chatting with friends
we're trying teams off cliffs and forza
i'm trying new games in game pass
this is where we live
and we've all seen how important and
real those human relationships can be
especially in the face of real life
adversity that's probably me so when i
think about 20 years i think about you
your community and our creators
and i want you to know that i'm
dedicated team xbox is dedicated and
this company is dedicated to continuing
to invest
listen and learn as we build the best
most welcoming and most fun
entertainment ecosystem anywhere on
earth and beyond
i remember when that nx
we're on a mission to bring the joy and
community of gaming to everyone and
we're honored that you've joined us for
the last 20 years and we can't wait to
build the future together
so thank you and see you online
thanks also
his name is jacob i met him like three
years ago on call of duty black ops
three so over the next year he quickly
i'm so sorry they haven't been on black
ops 3
but of course that's a strong
relationship though i've never seen one
person
spoke in washington but i was like bro
i'm gonna be in canada no way he's here
me and monkey it's supposed to be up
there literally yeah
florida new york
[Music]
he switched at the worst time ever like
how you switch to playstation now
i got the worst luck in the world
as soon as you switch over to that horse
you put all my money on that horse right
there in his leg break oh 2015 that's my
first one xbox gamers and we're grateful
for your that's when he was just fine
we continue to
last year the team decided to tackle a
feature that has been consistently at
the top of your request i was there for
this this blew the line for the back
compatible
backwards compatibility i'm pleased to
announce xbox one backward compatibility
because mass is affecting like two other
games with the first one the bar had
came out
after that that's what i meant bill
he's one of the people in the middleware
and the games you want to continue to be
played crazy will be playable natively
on your xbox one
[Applause]
you asked for more games to join our
backward compatibility catalog from the
biggest blockbusters
and xbox one consoles for the very i do
know i have on my headset right the
entire thing i don't know why we hear
you echo there on our latest machines
games like dead are alive ultimate and
star wars jedi knight 2 jedi outcast i
don't know where i would have missed
all original xbox games will look better
than ever on all modern consoles
every one of the titles added today will
benefit from auto hdr up the fear and
many will enjoy increased frame rates
with fps boost including a wider range
of our existing backward compatible
titles like the gears of war franchise
yes the fable franchise
and sonic activations
at xbox we are committed to preserving
the games that you love
thank you for being with us on every
step of this journey
from the bolt from the vaults
360 air
yeah baby
feed it more away peter boy got to come
through
once in a tattoo at that
what that was a perfect dog
oh there here we go the golden era
the cathedral look peed outside
avatar's debut
crack down we had a promise
yes yes stole the show
fable three
halo 2 was insane
fall out you ever wonder what the bottom
of an avatar
project
shout out to tim though he had that
shirt that show he had on when i first
met him i have project guitar
we have milo and a little boy that he
scared everybody here
yes
minecraft
huge because bethesda had all a joints
over there so there was a relationship
from the crackdown
that look like gears next time yeah
oh that was so exciting all right xbox
fans
can you believe it has been 20 years
since i stood on that ces stage yeah i
like how they brought him
symmetric multi-processing completely
self-contained operating system and how
about that look i mean he's a better
actor the glasses who wears glasses
just like the x-box he got stronger and
bolder sleeping
i left the fanny pack in my closet yes
i hope you had a chance to watch red
notice on netflix over the weekend now
here's the thing i feel like
you know yeah
i'm doing this
he was there from day one
ryan reynolds
now i'm excited to tell you we got worse
than halloween hundreds of amazing
prizes including an oil painting of
yours truly from that moment 20 years
ago the look the glasses the hair
and custom xbox red notice hardware
games
i saw it already now
none of this interests me can we get to
the real stuff clear
now we got to let rock get his blog
[Music]
okay i'm further
[Music]
okay
no that's exactly the hottest playing
game on um playstation right now
fortnite
right
[Music]
peter did that
if peter doesn't say that that doesn't
happen
that's the last year we went wasn't it
yeah peter threw him off script that was
last year everybody won
[Music]
i mean
considering jack kirby was the the key
author on that be like all right yeah
that's pretty good
yes i did yeah
that's something i would go for
i used a halo helmet i'll rock that
every show
the vision that we've worked on for so
long
[Applause]
oh
no documentary no pictures no games
nothing no announcements
see you next year
september we centered on the site
definitely oh i'm trying to hear this
really freeing up the players
that's the vision
it will connect people
[Music]
it will empower i need somebody to
support me while i game because i want
to know if i look like these dudes
it will break down
[Music]
more than a chance to reflect on all
we've done and everything our
with 23 studios across xbox game studios
and bethesda all pouring their
incredible passion into creating it's a
pretty bad echo key
echo
our love for players starts with our
love for games and the creators who make
them
we know that to reach more gamers in
more parts of the world we need to keep
bringing more creative voices and
perspectives to the table
fostering a community as diverse as the
world we live in and inclusive of all
that makes each of us who we are
that's why we relentlessly invest to
make it easier and faster for developers
to build the games we love we've driven
innovation to enable developers to build
accessibility features into their games
like remappable controls and adjustable
color or text for players who are
visually impaired
we collaborate with creators to
encourage representation of diverse
characters for stories that can open our
eyes and our hearts to new points of
view and we're committed to bringing
those incredible games to every gamer on
the planet by making it possible for
anyone to play any game anywhere we do
that with game pass bringing you
hundreds of titles from hidden gems to
the biggest hits playable across all
devices we do that with our consoles the
most affordable and powerful console
lineup with xbox series s and x
and we do that with things like the xbox
adaptive controller which has unlocked
the joy of gaming for over 400 million
players with disabilities
when everyone plays we all win it isn't
just a tagline it's a core principle
that inspires everything we do
so please join us as we look forward to
the next 20 years and more as we unleash
creativity embrace a global community
and delight gamers
everywhere together
thank you for being the core of what
makes xbox great
correct salute craig thank you
our duty as soldiers is to protect
humanity halo infinite time maybe yeah
infinite time
paramount plus what i'm over the movie
oh
augmentations
oh we're actually gonna do this
we've been talking about this like for
10 years like it might be happening
hello master chief
oh
finally new series
streaming okay
i got to order that
ah yes
phil davis want you to bend the knee
and where millions of experiences can be
shared
halo began 20 years ago
thanks to you
it's now
hilarious
the highly anticipated halo tv series
coming to paramount plus next year which
you just saw a glimpse in that live
action teaser or stepping back into the
boots of master chief in halo infinite
this december
the halo universe continues to expand in
new and thrilling ways
because of your passion for halo
and your constructive feedback we gave
halo infinite more time
to refine it for everyone that has been
with us from the beginning feels like
something for anyone who's just getting
started
this game is returned to our roots with
an epic campaign and a deeply rewarding
multiplayer and we can't wait for you to
jump into this all-new halo experience
while the master chief is the hero of
halo
our fans are its heart and soul
and we at 343 are proud to celebrate 20
years of halo with you in a very special
way in a special way
what special way would you like to enjoy
this with us
how would you like us to partake
oh that's this good music thing
[Music]
oh
[Music]
right now
last time we saw somebody with a flute
didn't end well
[Laughter]
i don't like that that's ominous get
that guy out of there now you know
who i said was just a bad
[Laughter]
lady we got him back baby
he brings back the cinematic
okay
then they're gonna do a side little tv
show of uh showing king and his team
going in to say sean from the bushes
[Music]
chance popping yeah
somebody oil up his chest put the baby
on him
the halo
soundtrack and music is just still too
good for that said
i ordered the digity do do with the piss
nipples he doesn't have somebody pissed
his nipples now
[Laughter]
get out there blow the digital dude
kind of crazy they got a whole orchestra
this is amazing
why is just him out there with the no
shirt like that yeah because he got the
baby powder on
[Music]
they said oil them up and smack them
with baby powder
now they respected the culture that's
why they're doing it so what are we
doing halo baby hello halo community
from
[Applause]
to everyone who played in the recent
multiplayer flights your passion and
feedback and spectacular gameplay clips
inspired all of us as we made the final
push to get halo infinite ready for
launch as a thank you and to celebrate
our 20th anniversary we wanted to do
something special oh really let me hand
the mic to tom french what special would
you like to do
tom
thank you oh joy what is this the entire
halo team it's my honor and privilege to
announce that your spartan journey
begins today
right now you can download and start
playing season one of halo infinite's
free to play multiplayer beta on xbox
one series s it's live today this is the
kickoff of our season and you'll have
access to all the maps core modes
academy features
so we get some available yeah
you like it this is an amazing
they said and moment is how we continue
to kick the chief in on the competition
you know we got to go play that right
our 20th anniversary we put out stuff
on their 25th anniversary that gets
nothing
seven
wait 20 more years but nothing more
[Music]
[Music]
let's see how quick we went from 170
something to one we're talking about the
strike while the iron is hot it's just
like this was up here and also we also
got to think to the
deal what you call it the um the quarter
the holiday
they're trying to get they're here they
just they not playing they see it yeah
they say they're going out the call of
duty and battlefields and everybody else
dude
preorder battlefield still trying to get
your money back
the battlefield pretty nice but i mean
yes
he gave him the two oh freedom
who is that guy
what's going on what's happening season
one is available
the actual game comes up
but you know yeah hey man i'm back
now
what they'll do is
that's how they're going to excuse all
the
problems right now
i'm already on downloading it
all right wait wait wait wait
downloading
is it the regular joint is it oh it's a
new joint i i don't know i'm looking i
just got to where did you download it
from i'm i'm on uh xbox right now
looking xbox.com or the console uh xbox
the console
you got your console
no no i just i just i just turned it on
you can just pull it up on your phone
and
it knowing they service probably gonna
see if download
get destroyed that's why i'm trying to
get it now over the celebration is over
yeah i think it thinks i can get 30
minutes all right so we back out our
jointer
okay delilah beta until launch but
progression carries over oh yeah okay
okay okay
you know i just see my entire friend
list just jump online
yep
yo
crazy
like just do something like this
there's something special i don't even
know where it's at to be honest in
general like if
if more groups did that's like hey this
game you've been waiting for available
now
like that just blows people's
[Music]
you see it
i'm fixing our screen real quick first
okay yeah no problem yeah i'm looking
for it on the story see if y'all see it
on the store i got it where you got it
from here oh i might have an info
download the console
okay
install it to this console in the living
room yes
oh my god
yes thank you
oh
xbox you're so wonderful
[Laughter]
[Music]
i just got the thing right now where
it's saying it's updated
oh okay y'all gonna make me leave this
straight
we're gonna get this super chat
somewhere
and i'm gonna make sure that i play it
with this
[Laughter]
bones
um
other than that
um i'm just glad they did something
amazing and
actually what people thought was gonna
happen
am i lucky my lucky
xbox uh game pass jump
is still in effect still working here's
how i went
up the
thank you so so when i shoot you you
know what i sound like
yeah boy
i just yo what'd you think
i i don't agree with it i know you
didn't agree i remember from a business
standpoint i don't agree with it but as
a fan
right so i'm torn right yeah and i'm
pretty sure that inside microsoft
they're torn as well
and um i'm pretty sure that the forza
team if i'm gonna tell you right now and
if this affects them negatively
at any point in time they're gonna say i
told you so and it might cause a
division inside inside the gaming part
of the groups but okay
they must understand that being now in
in the game pass
it is to grow game pads to keep them in
yeah
all could be
you got you may be onto something could
be
remember the numbers yes the internal
targets and they could say yo if we do
halo now we can guarantee yeah it's the
game pass
engagement target yes
i'm going with you you own it yeah
it has to it has to keep growing go in
right so
how else do you uh grow game pass and
sovereign says it's being a sovereign's
not here i'm going to speak on his
behalf for this part here
um
exclusive grows new numbers
right so those exclusive games and halo
infinite will be exclusive to the
console in the exclusive form but in the
beta form this and this is why it's
behind beta right because the free to
play is going to be everywhere right so
then you don't have to jump to here
today to to play the free to play but
the beta is probably going to be locked
behind game pass or on the xbox console
so you must engage through the xbox in
order to raise those numbers so i can
see how that can actually work and that
kind of makes sense if you want to keep
engagement inside the same ecosystem so
yeah so shout out to foreign
[Laughter]
you do what you do you go uh go to halo
infinite you click the one that says
campaign but when you click it it comes
in two uh there's two different files
halo infinite wait where you click you
on the console yeah yeah okay
no pull it up on your phone okay
all right pull up the xbox um app on
your phone put in halo infinite go to
games click it and download it once you
download it like he said you're gonna
see the two files but regardless to what
you downloaded the whole join anyway
okay
okay
8 million yeah but we'll see how that
goes well we'll be interested in the
track
is the end of the week
what forwards is does he kick that's
king's frustration he wants to see
forza's numbers there but as an overall
game pass thing yeah overall numbers
will will increase and if they have
internal targets for the stockholders to
say hey
buy the by end of november by december
we was anticipating x y and z number
then maybe that that's a surefire way
for gay gay
i'm gonna say this right knowing that
you have uh eight million eyes watching
forza and plays and playing forza right
now
you will hope that at least half of
those numbers will migrate instantly
over to halo infinite multiplayer right
and if you can get that engagement
number to leap over in at least a 60 40
percentage rate
over to uh halo infinite multiplayer and
on top of that the people that didn't
engage with forza
you can cross-pollinate between uh old
games right so let's say those people
are playing uh halo infinite and there's
like oh this forza look kind of hot on
my dashboard because it's um highlighted
on the dashboard you might pollinate
over this way to check that out in
between time and the same thing vice
versa for forza so you might be sharing
the same 8 million and it might double
so you can grow both fan bases
technically uh by the cross pollination
between games shout out to the muffin
mon he said we got the multiplayer guys
let's go
no doubt is that the muffin manager
project x talk that that is that is he
when didn't see the other his brother um
shout out to cmbr i saw a lock that man
let me hear what he got to say that's my
financial guru he said the shareholders
are not too worried about xbox it's only
about five to eight percent of
microsoft's business that is true that
is true i'm just worried i'm just
interested about
their uh
internal targets for gay past
subscribers that's what i was thinking
about but uh yeah just shout out to e
you bought this so that was back compat
but really mostly to announce yeah halo
multiple so what they did is they kept
expectation low by making it like it was
just going to be a regular show you know
just some you know what you call
nostalgic type joint and then from there
that was the stealth job but they they
went through it
addict your thoughts sir
um it was it was good i mean i didn't
expect anything like serious from it
no no but what about the the decision
off again it's on again it's off again
um if it's gonna get cancelled i don't
know what
i don't know what happened like behind
closed doors or anything but uh
it they they they needed something out
right now regardless
how they feel about forza and regardless
how forza is doing it's not halo and
they still want to meet those those
those numbers so
so you are do you agree with it yes i
agree with them
because at the end of the day it's not
halo like
like forza is going to do well the
people that were going to play forza
they're going to play that regardless
so no it's true it's real we're gonna
see but the kick's point i do want to
see towards the horizon i want to see
the numbers by the end of the night by
the end of the year end of the night
also by the end of the week oh that's
just that that's probably dropped half
by
what i'm now about because those numbers
were steadily climbing
i want to see
after this drop yeah what happened does
those numbers fall because if those
numbers fall then those people that was
arguing not to do it is going to be
looked at as right
right and then those people that's
arguing that we had to get it done
they're going to have to hold their
ground because their numbers is going to
have to equally impress if not so let me
ask you a question what happens if
forza drops down to four to five million
but hey look it's 20 million
then that means the people that were
arguing 4 1
that argument they don't have to get 20
million
right they have to equal and surpass and
this is in beta so we have to temper
those expectations because they're not
labeling as a beta though i'm looking at
it now they're not labeling those on the
table
the real grandest scheme for the actual
game is free to play everywhere right so
we expect those numbers those engagement
numbers to be rambunctious but
these numbers will be a little bit
tempered so if it equals
forza or or comes in at 10 million then
it's a success from those people's fight
excuse me
all right this had a stream
yes i watched it i watched that stream i
heard a lot of bug fixes yeah no no so i
didn't and that's another thing it's
still inside game pass and i'm about to
go over there and touch it up because
there ain't no new content i heard
though
yeah they talked about the new um uh i
didn't i didn't so no i didn't say that
it's not that they're not internally
labeling as a beta but on the xbox store
it's not labeled as a beta the majority
of people are going to see that that
tile on the xbox store they're not going
to know that on the live stream they
announced this it said beta they're
going to see it not say beta on the
store
it's gonna be interesting let's get
these super chats right quick so we can
get the hell up out of here yeah yeah
boys i gotta go get my controller
because everybody's gonna be pissed off
all right so let's go
no he would not hand it over to me until
i gave my government yeah they're not
playing no games yeah he's like yo
microsoft said no
they they know they know they know the
boys is out here
shout out let's start with these super
chats uh warlord uh find out some chat
lots of channels live streaming this and
i always choose to be in the realm with
the lord's notification gang we are here
salute general mack find out super chat
all hail the iop happy 20th anniversary
happy and happy boy to my lord my man
lord cognito and my cog voice no doubt
lucious augustus follow us which i had
to come and show love to iop and the
wondrous and illustrious lord if oh man
y'all killing me right now happy
birthday brother and happy the ball
eliad shulman
since super chats were enabled here only
recently i'm happy my first one in the
realm to bid the boss vista shinobi
himself a happy boring day salute vader
blade uh with the five pounds super chat
hi lords happy new year's day to the
lord god also i'm a happy extra happy
day got my series x halo edition salute
chaos might find out super chat
expectation will be more halo news maybe
early access announcement fps boost from
xbox 360 then maybe hellblade 2 and
fabled oh um addict did we find out the
list that they put out the list for all
what the back compact games were i'm
very curious i haven't i haven't worked
i don't put in my fable too right now
and get my fornication
absolutely
ready to play with the 2000 chat happy
birthday today and at the game of the
year fable and a vow ready blade again
two pound super chat it's all about
viewing levels game of the year for
forza horizon 5 game of the year brandon
blade again two pounds super chat i'd
love to be invited to ilp i'm next no
doubt michael mooney two pal super chat
tag ran and xbox buzz nintendo tweet
okay
raiden blade 2 passenger hey king i
received my series x halo edition bro
yes sir
cedric h 20 super chat happy birthday
card at 20 years of xbox salute bro har
gee shinny 2 super chat halo show coming
november 15th in the game pass app okay
the show so he saw it earlier angel
gonzalez 500 chat what's good lords
hoping for some backpack news back
compact news today and maybe the halo
infinite multiplayer launch you got that
spartan goal 17 two pounds super chat i
thought phil was speaking from heaven or
something
gerald mack follow super chat or hail to
iop oh he put it again happy 20th
anniversary happy xbox happy birthday to
lordcon in my cog voice no doubt craig
hoogheim
two dollar or canadian um sorry
battlefield guess you should have took
the game pass back
this is true
that's it right there this is what
happens when you don't listen yeah maybe
they got smacked over there you wanna
take it baby they was gonna wait because
they didn't take the bag and they moved
it
oh you don't want it all right we're
gonna take that spot
really eagle father chad the homie good
afternoon lords ladies and gamers i
missed the show but we're watching the
replay much love the iop
you're going to be on we're going to
play this game or what what's going on
apollo dingo follow super chat this
isn't just about game pass halo
multiplayer live on stream right on
steam
right now oh that's right free to play
get everywhere everywhere that's rewrite
oh my god yeah eagles fan 76 it's two
dollars super chat spaces today philip
phil lies talk for releasing halo
that's what this space is going to be
what side is he he's probably got to
write
[Music]
20 super chat just told matty y'all need
king on defining duke yeah i'll talk to
kim about that simping the king lots of
love to y'all
lord skew remember for 14 months low
bronze just put yo put the cream of
wheat down cog
it's not no porridge
[Laughter]
i guess
will be playing fable 2 and 60 f in
frames per second all right
i'm gonna load it up baby mass correct
2000 canadian happy birthday card can't
wait to smash halo that is it seriously
right there
wait hold on stop playing kurt don't lie
to me don't say they added 50 cent blood
on the sand don't you do that
wow they added 50 seconds that's
licensed music i don't know if they can
get that but maybe because they get 50.
that'll be crazy the halo infinites
aren't working for anyone he's not
working for a year you don't even bless
the service you know i gotta get me time
to go to the gym but um
yeah i'm good i'm good laughing at y'all
bro
we've been through this rodeo as destiny
fans we know how this goes okay here's
the list
all right let's break it down break down
let me get it 50 cent blood on the sand
stop playing is it there it's in there
wait oh
my god
[Music]
are you smarter than a fifth grader
avatar the last airbender it's a lot of
stuff though isn't it
yeah it's it's a few yeah tell him to go
find the list but he's got something we
gotta go he's gonna drive he said we're
gonna go
oh they got a lot of star wars
chat oh my god the backing padlist
bananas they doing it again
happy birthday
hurry up we got the best community damn
it we love them i love them too
is that kevin johnson
hurry up and read it
been gone for two months but i brought a
house this was a great show to slide
hey what's up new xbox egg happy
birthday salute raided blade five pounds
super chat great show guys i'm not
looking forward to the next 20 20 studio
acquisitions you ready carl i'll join
you soon
no doubt drunken ninja two dollars happy
boring day con the best industry inside
of the i am not an insider i don't know
what's happening but it is very
coincidental anyway i'm out look
everybody enjoy your day happy birthday
for the birthday love see y'all on halo
when it's up i'm about to give you my
kid control and remember
when you get shot by me it's worse with
this
catch y'all later peace
[Music]
it's fan oh
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you